[Music]
you're so burned out after 10 years of
Transformers bayham she's a minor we'll
protective mother Romeo and Juliet laws
statute
2705-3 let you kind of skip the only
good one but before Paramount resorts to
bestiality return to a film so 80s two
different robots turn into boomboxes and
their cassette tapes fight each other
[Music]
Bodacious the Transformers the movie
buckle up for a film that feels like
Game of Thrones but for cartoon robots
that turn into things
two opposing sides of murder Bots murder
the out of each other for 90
minutes great that doesn't even pause to
mourn the deaths of long-running
characters until they force children to
watch the live slowly drain from Optimus
Prime's body because the only thing more
ruthless than this script is the
Shameless corporate breed that inspired
it the reality is at the time it was a
toy show we just thought we were killing
off the old product line introducing the
new products gnarly you're used to a
world where Transformers movies are 90
Josh dumel 10 fighting robots now watch
them flip that ratio for better or worse
[Music]
in this Timeless Adventure about a new
generation of Autobots tasked to save
Cybertron and wow it does not go over
them
tremble and fear at the dawn of Unicron
a planet eating God that's part Galactus
and part Mega made from Spaceballs he's
voiced by Cinema Legend Orson Wells or
at least the dying wheezes of Cinema
Legend Orson Wells buried under layers
of sin
[Music]
in a performance he couldn't have cared
less about if it were a Paul Mason wine
commercial action please
ah the French champagne has always been
celebrated for its excellence
are you ready to rock because this movie
has the best 80s music since Rocky IV
featuring the composer who scored Rocky
IV with enough hair metal jammed into
every second to kick off a combiner's
worth of 80 satanic Panic featuring hits
like Stan Bush's power Rock ballad the
Touch You Got The Touch
Stan Bush's powerock ballot the touch
again you got the touch and Stan Bush's
power Rock ballad the touch one more
time for good measure
a Rock ballad so powerful Stan Bush
wrote it for Sylvester Stallone's Cobra
and is probably why Mark Wahlberg doing
the franchise down the line
We Salute You Mr Bush tired of modern
Transformers franchises that take
forever to get to the fan favorite cash
heads I mean characters well strap in as
Hasbro desperately tries to hold the
attention of an eight-year-old audience
all hopped up on New Coke I'm trying to
get them into the shuttle Ultra Magnus
because I know he can't watch the
shuttle until I get into the shuttle I
can't
from the insecticons
to the Dinobots Dinobots destroy
devastation radar to the Constructor
cards
the shark decons
the courtesans and their cruel
mastersounds to a living version of the
junkyard where all of these toys live
now
[Music]
go let them all no seriously by law
we're not allowed to finish the trailer
until you go buy a toy after the film is
done killing childhoods
me the replacement parts like Ultra
Magnus another big truck but without the
nuts cup and hot rod just bought it I
can't deal with that now blur a cocaine
what does that means what about me RC
the only female Transformer who raises
all the same uncomfortable questions
posed by the existence of Smurfette
wheelie a weird rhyming homeschooled kid
Judd Nelson's hot rod who's not the
stepdad but the dad who stepped up fish
are jumping today hi Dano and Daniel
widwickey a child both adopted and
abandoned by the Autobots what do I do
creating a bloodline so traumatized it
would one day produce Shia LaBeouf no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
so returned to the year 2005. it is the
year 2005. for a toy commercial that has
no right to kick as much as it does I
got better things to do tonight
that may be kind of light on your actual
favorite Transformers soon I shall be
one with the Matrix but hey look it's
Astro train he turns into a train that's
also a rocket that's pretty cool right I
mean you never know when you're gonna
need a old-timey space train who's also
a rocket why don't we kill this guy off
again
catch the surprise return of Optimus
Prime coming soon to the Transformer oh
thank Primus
starring
dogs like a truck truck truck we have
Optimus Prime at home I think I'm a gun
now orbit Wells unsolved matrices is
that Canon I'm the Scatman people
G is for Grimlock they're good enough
for me ancient aliens that are also
robots the storyline
energize is a hell of a drug real
Autobots have curves my name is Danny
the D is for dingus King for a Day and
okay the cool charismatic guy with a
sword is right there and he's not
getting the Matrix the assassination of
Optimus Prime by the coward Hasbro
hey if you thought this movie was too
much for kids wait until breast force
and Headmaster show up Transformers can
be weird man
here's Optimus Prime my name is Optimus
Prime and I like to say things like no
matter the cost give me your face by the
power of Grace call I have the power I
am going to turn into a truck now